Today I would like to talk
about the theme of the language learner's poison 1 declaration
.
No
, I have to take the lead. So I thought about it this morning, and I made
up a declaration of independence in
English.
Solio First, read it in English, then I can read it in Japanese
.  No, I'm not going to ask if a
third party can study it for me.
Everything depends on me.
I decide my own study activities based on
my interests
.
What is my level
? My evaluation is important.
It's limited to what I'm interested in
. Isn't it the position that a third party decides?
I decide.
I chose the
content I heard about the content That's the way to understand it To express it That's the way to
express it
That's the question of a house where strangers live Well, did
you understand?  Didn't you hear the content
?
For those who are studying leaves,
it is one of their rights to do what Solio Mouri does not do.
inoreader Percy the voodoo me well
impo s bar Tunnow Winty Nakamae Cash Dubai So
words with no words
and
questions about the denominator
I have an eye for that kind of thing today
Hirabe when there is advertising money  I'm going
to study Now, the teacher says that you should study 90%
I'm not going to go, I'll take the initiative and when I'm interested, when I'm
curious  4 q 3 In the at section of communication,
when speaking in the new language of the 4th school, the goal is
to communicate with people, isn't it
? It's not the goal to speak perfectly
.
p Polar Fate
4 pieces p No armor team to give me bebo ios to be clean car
with caress then sway
Whether they criticize or evaluate me,
or whether they will do that, I
can be independent from
everything like that.
I will be independent from
Wakana-san. Today is
[music]
That matter
.